freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag für sind auch heute
durch eine sehr besondere folge denn ich
habe alex zu gast kommen gerne mal ins
bett und du hast mal gehen dabei aber
viel wichtiger so ist sehr gerne
gewinnen aber das ist das was hier
wirklich entscheidest und wir freuen uns
hier schon zusammen stehen für french
toast das was er zum frühstück gewünscht
eine sehr gute entscheidung und ich hab
dann gelingt los sehr schnelles
frühstück du kannst eigentlich komplett
ich habe schon kaffee gemacht und musste
gleich nur essen was bei der einzige
aufgabe heute also als erstes müssen wir
natürlich unsere bremsscheiben und ich
hab schon einmal ausgemacht wir machen
heute aber eine besondere die perfekte
version von verschluss wir brauchen also
dieses weiche französischen brot wichtig
man kann es auch mit toast machen muss
aber nicht ich sagt ehrlich das ist auf
jeden fall leicht wenn man es nicht
machen kann dann schlagen wir
zweierreihen robert professional ist
jemand auf und fern sind da
da gehen wir so 100 wie komme ich dazu
machst du sind ja wir hatten für david
du hast schon sowie tiefe kraft geben
management gefühlt also ich habe vor
zwei jahren ungefähr das meist privat
und war krass ja also ich hab schon echt
über 100 kilo marke und auch da habe ich
wirklich das ist es also oder die diese
nulldiät oder auch ein paar kraft oder
kirchen müssten
den sonst keiner lassen und nicht zum
beispiel tatsächlich etwas finde ich
immer so beträchtlich ständig berichte
über mich da steht nach kampfsport ich
hab gesagt die mannschaft eigentlich
muss man so kamen
das haben wir schon mal klargestellt
wurde macht so richtig so mit gewichten
und ambitioniert so nicht nur fit halten
sondern auch so k
also ich hab eine gewisse zeit für mich
war das heißt so
ich weiß ja nur schlank werden sondern
ich will natürlich auch meinen körper so
weit wie möglich formen ja dann gerade
die muskeln aufbauen einen bestimmten
partien ist ganz hilfreich zur
wirksamkeit die letzten sechs monate ich
mich auch so gewissen haben also leute
doch überall so ja tatsächlich ich
glaube ich habe dr
wir haben vorher so kast gut
vorgearbeitet das habe ich auch das
gefühl dass man also niederkassel tore
sport habe ich habe das gefühl dass
haben sich wirklich so eine
unsportlichkeit erarbeiten wir haben und
dann hat man das so sehen sich beziehen
das ist ja einmal durchlaufen ist ein
bisschen ein weilchen in dieser mischung
ich ein bisschen zucker noch ein gemacht
haben das ganze bald mit ordentlicher
teller deshalb habe ich da mal ein
bisschen gespart süß genug wird auf
jeden fall
und das muss auf jeden fall einmal gut
durch weichen da würden wir schon
gefahren heißt hat man direkt ein
gruppen von beiden seiten goldbraun
backen pwg das direkt mit ihr rein ganz
leicht am zwischen dass ich sehr gut
weil wir wollen keine zuletzt das muss
ja auch gut durch baken und hier drüben
habe ich auch noch mal ein bisschen
butter waren werden lassen in einer
unbeschichteten pfanne darin flambieren
jetzt da geht es schnell ein bisschen
zucker rein
wir gehen wir uns schluss wasser dazu
zusammenschmolz ich gebe jetzt die bären
hier mit zum karamellisiertem zucker und
schwenkt die einmal ein bisschen mit
durch das gibt dann sowieso eine instant
bären marmelade und wird unser top inc
event mal forderte däke das schön an
gebäuden gold frauen so muss ich sein
wir gehen jetzt einen guten schluck
wodka dazu lassen das ganze nochmal
schön heiß werden und dann flambieren
wie es der alkohol verbrennt das ganze
kocht ein
dann reduzieren wir es noch mal mit ein
bisschen mehr zucker schön goldbraun
also alex hier ist ein frühstück wird
ein bisschen darauf warten dass man wir
uns hier gut unterhalten ein freistoß
mit einer klamm piloten wäre marmelade
nutella puderzucker auch hier folgen
gesondert stadtinternen lasst uns
probieren der wenigen die erste kamera
geht aus ganz ganz in ruhe auf es und in
ganz erst zur bewertung wider dass man
solche erst mal anders machen mal gar
nicht kennt also das muss man
differenziert das schon aber nur einmal
im jahr okay da ist wo ich ja schon mal
magath ab ich fand das richtig gut ist
noch ein sehr großer fan davon wenn das
nicht so kurzfristig die absolventen
holt ihr okay für macht auch ein
bisschen mut gemacht schmeckt so gut
fall so schlecht kann schon mit spott
ich bin prinzipiell auch gut aber ich
bin nicht so aber ich kann für mich
sagen von 10.2 mal genauer zeitpunkt ja
schon vor acht okay das für sie ist
schon sehr sehr wohl
ja es wird nämlich sehr deftig ab sofort
alex liebt absolut deftiges essen und
werde ich auf jeden fall abliefern wobei
eigentlich sind mittagessen auslöst ja
das ist mir auf die ich hatte war und
ich denke so gern gehört zu bekommen
ganz des schwerts wegen nutzer sind
sowie machen wir gerne mit einer selbst
gemachten vanillesoße aber erst mal
kümmern wir uns um den hefeteig ich habe
ja alles bei seiner maschine wird für
mich arbeiten und jemand alles hier in
die schüssel rhein erst mal 250 gramm
mehl dann kommt dazu fünf gramm
trockenhefe zwei esslöffel zucker eine
prise salz
ich habe die mich ein bisschen warm
gemacht dass aktiviert die hier
verantwortung bisher habe ich auch dazu
planen kommen dazu noch 25 haben
geschmolzene butter und ein eigene und
jetzt müssen wir einfach nur das ganze
an stellen darauf brauche ich jetzt so
eine kleine kugel einmal kurz dann
lassen wir es für eine stunde gehen und
das ticket für eigentlich nur freunde
das hier ist nicht der tag den wir
gemacht haben videos ist teilt nummer
drei ich habe schon so angst dass es
nicht funktionieren würde das g2
supermärkten warum germknödel zu kommen
haben nichts bekommen aber der dritte
tag hat mich nicht im stich gelassen er
ist gut aufgegangen bei den beiden davor
war die idee für todt ich weiß nicht ob
es am samstag keine ahnung aber geklappt
wir haben jetzt den teig das ist sehr
gut darin könnt ihr arbeitet mehr auf
die gemälde arbeitsfläche heißt es bei
dir zeigen dass deswegen fällt auch
unter bitte wieder klein ja wo ist davon
genau das habe ich mich auch gefragt ihr
wisst es bestimmt schreibt werden weil
die kommentare gewährleistungs
durchlesen detail das jetzt in sechs
gleich große stücke
kassel das ist ein gern dass ungefähr
gleichgroßen daraus vorne ich jetzt so
kleine fladen quasi platz sind weil dann
können wir das ganze für kopfhörer ist
das gut wird wenn ja wenn ich danach
passierte dann hat sich getan hat sich
wirklich für immer gern könnte wenn das
jetzt nicht funktioniert jetzt kommt
jeweils ein esslöffel pflaumenmus in die
mitte
ich habe auch nicht zu viel daran dass
ich die auf dem gut zu bekommen gleicht
der leute es war so eine schwere geburt
zu diesen zu diesem wirklich und jetzt
nehme ich mir die einfach und trifft die
erst mal oben so zusammen und dann von
den seiten sich so rein dass nur noch 15
minuten dann geschlossen so die ferkel
sind sofort fertig unter dem handtuch
aber wir bereit schnell die vanillesoße
ford 400 milliliter milch dazugeben wir
drei esslöffel zucker und das mag
der vanilleschote der länge nach
aufschneiden auskratzen
und die kann man auch mit rein geben zum
aufkochen und auch die geschmäcker wir
uns einfach raus
da gebe ich mir jetzt zwei eier hinein
man sagt ja immer essen ungesund das was
man manchmal ist ja auch so 814 kann ich
empfehlen also laufen einfach wir hatten
so einwohner vorschlag trifft eine
probefahrt angestellten haben wir
schlagen die eier schutz auf dazu kommt
jetzt ein ganzer becher sahne und ein
teelöffel speisestärke so die milch ist
jetzt aufgekocht dann gehe ich direkt
ein bisschen runter mit der hitze und
gebt den rest dazu also die sahne und
die stärke und lass das ganze jetzt noch
mal so ein bisschen eindicken einkochen
aber die stärker macht auf jeden fall
schon ihre arbeit werden wir uns bei
drei von unseren lehrern knödeln ein
bisschen größer waren ja da kommt noch
mal was und setzen sie auch dieses sie
drauf und damit gehen wir jetzt in den
top 3 so schlecht das ganze jetzt rein
und wir warten so für zwölf minuten
freunde die vanillesoße ist sehr welt
geworden hat eine sehr gute konsistenz
keine klumpen ich bin sehr zufrieden ich
geb noch ein bisschen mond oder zucker
hier wäre das ein bisschen durch und
dann sagen wir es gleich durch den sieg
[Musik]
leonskaja erstmal ne bratwurst gemacht
weil motto es war nicht für auszeiten
wir haben so lange gewartet dass das
funktioniert aber da sehen sie wir haben
es geschafft alex ich danke dir für
deine betrifft ich danke dir zwei gerne
voraus auf den teller also für den
erfolg gibt es auf jeden fall schon mal
ein extra punkte heimat machen
das war wirklich spaß richtig guck mal
die aufgegangen ist ich habe ihm gesagt
das will ich sagen das war's das man
nicht habe noch einen fertig leute alles
ist wirklich eine maschine
ja ich hab hier ja wirklich also du bist
auf jeden fall ein guter gast bei der
wird doch nur mal das aufgegessen
wir können ja trotzdem schon mal die
bewertung haben und ich bin sehr sehr
gespannt was zu sagen wird hey wurden
sowieso gibt es ja schon mal ein extra
punkten danke schön dass das wäre dann
wirklich klasse dann hatte ich ja kurz
angst dass du keinen draht nach hertz
technik punkte abzunehmen
also ich würde sagen da sagt ich muss
ein bisschen klaren muster zu tun
das stimmt ja in den wald von 10 915 hab
ich mit super system brechen
der dritte gang das abendessen wird
nochmals im kracher ich hoffe es wird
weniger problematischer ist das
mittagessen
aber wir sehen uns jetzt gleich beim
zürcher geschnetzelte züricher
geschnetzeltes mit spätzle ich werde als
erstes den speziell vorbereitet hatte
schon oberschale vom kalb das ist das
fleisch was man dafür braucht aber
erstmal ein schwätzer tag so wir nehmen
uns zunächst mal 600 gramm mehl darauf
geben wie jetzt sechs eier also es ist
denkbar einfach
100 gramm mehl 1 1 kommt dazu eine gute
prise salz und jetzt können wir schon
anfangen das ganze zu verarbeiten aber
ist jetzt erst mal von mengen ihr seht
schon mit wasser bereitstehen das konnte
aber erstmal nicht dass mir das so
aussieht geben wir nach und nach immer
ein bisschen wasser dazu und dann
wirklich auch auf die hände und knete
das ganze damit durch so leute und das
ist spitze zeigt das heißt wir werden
ihn jetzt schlagen bis er glatt ist und
blasen wird so fertig so wir legen jetzt
zu und parallel hat sich schon mal eben
vor ich habe schon meine spätzle presse
die ich mir extra neu gekauft habe auf
dem herd
wir machen jetzt aber erstmal das
geschnetzelte sich 800 gramm butter
schale das ist schon eine gute portion
so für viele leute und die schneiden wir
jetzt erstmal zu recht das rezept hier
für mich übrigens von karl absolute
legende als einen stellen jetzt erst
entdeckt er den fohlen dass man das am
stück kauft damit man große stücke
rausschneiden kann ich also genauso
machen die fangen jetzt möglichkeiten
gibt ja einen sonnenblumenöl weit
überhaupt echt hitze wir nicht ein paar
röstaromen rausbekommen wichtig dann
bereiten wir schon mal eine zwiebel vor
planes schnitte in die mitte und fein
schneiden ist fertig das nicht so
schnell wir ein paar scharping abbrennen
400 gramm hat sich geschnitten habe so
die fans gut heißt angeben jetzt das
kleid hinein
hier setzte er voll durchgefallen oder
zwei toren der auch nicht falsch gewesen
aber so brat mir das ganze jetzt folgen
dennoch schön an gebräunt ist können wir
auch einmal durchschwenken so deuten
darauf dass fleisch raus livestream zur
seite und dann schmelzen
ein gutes stück butter in der pfanne
wenn die buttergeschmack das kommt
unsere zwiebel drauf jetzt richtig schön
glasig werden lösen sich auch die ganzen
reststoffe vom braten so zielen sind
angeschwitzt jetzt geben wir unsere
champignons dazu sind wir auch durch
champignons sind eingefallen jetzt ein
bisschen mehr drüber
das hören wir um das gibt dem ganzen
eine schöne bindung pfeffer und salz
drüber und jetzt lassen wir das ganze
mit weißwein acht guten schluck
getrunken einmal hier unsere spätzle
presse ins wasser ein
vor gut seiten jetzt befüllen wir sie
ungefähr drei viertel voll machen wir
das ganze und dann können wir auch schon
loslegen und die spätzle weinpressen so
wenn hier drüben der weißwein gekauft
ist geben wir sahne dazu ordentlich
sahne so dazu geben wir jetzt wieder das
fleisch und den fleischsaft und lassen
es mit einkochen und reduzieren in
meinem ersten spätzle raus sind nicht
groß geworden aber kann nur besser
werden
also freuen ich möchte mich bei allen
schwaben in meiner community
entschuldigen ich weiß es sind keine
hübschen spätzle ich habe keine ahnung
wie man diese presse richtig benutzt
aber der geschmack auf denen kommt man
also kommt es jetzt zur hochzeit die
spätzle kommen zur soße wir mischen
alles durch und dann ist fertig
[Musik]
es ist soweit das abendessen das große
finale zürcher geschnetzeltes mit
spätzle und wie ihr sehen könnt ich habe
alexander ganztag immer schon eine cola
light versorgt das war glaube ich auch
sehr wichtig sonst wenn die stimmung der
basis selbst ja ganz anders aus lassen
es gerne probieren ich bin selbst
gespannt was ich da fabriziert habe dann
kann auf jeden fall großzügig zum teil
schwere monate bevor wir mal dass jemand
der gerne sage ich man kann nicht sagen
was haben sie aus wie ein schlachtfeld
alexander tff hat sich gelohnt zu kommen
heute definitiv sehr gut ich muss sagen
das sind nicht die schönsten schmerzen
die ich jemals gesehen habe in meinem
leben sind sich diese müssen aber
schmaler aber tatsächlich kommt es auf
die inneren werte an
eigentlich sein was ich nicht
schlammfeld ich mache das ja ja das
meine ich ja schon wieder so mag es so
sein sollte ist seit ich das war schon
eine hausnummer auch mit ecke besser
noch als die ampel für mich okay es ist
zwischen 9 und 10 915 finde ich 14 wegen
für mich dem fleisch das fleisch war
ticken zu durch ja so ein bisschen dass
wir dann zu wenig angenommen ein
bisschen selig hat ein bisschen zu viel
mist hab muss sich auch selbstkritisch
gesteht aber neuen halt heute also
wirklich alles habe ich spaß macht mit
dir heute hat jungs ihr müsst wissen
diese bewertung sind wirklich sehr gut
weil wir haben so hinter der kamera ein
bisschen gequatscht und alex ist übelste
feinschmeckerin und wer weiß vielleicht
sieht man sich ja noch mal auf meinem
schönen
krasses eskalation steinschmätzer video
bis dahin sind wir spätestens nächsten
sonntag wieder macht's gut und bist du
es da